family members retrieve remains of a
child buried under the mud in yamakumbi
village
the body of a nine-year-old girl will be
laid to rest close to what was once her
home
I have questions I have been looking for
my daughter I'm sad but I'm glad I found
her and I'll bury her decently
the community here is still in shock
people are trying to salvage whatever
they can from the wreckage others are
looking for the missing relatives
government officials brought aid but the
needs are too many they came with
coffins food and some cash
they displaced a living rough on heels
and in neighboring Villages but even
that is not safe
over 5 000 homes have been swept away
and only 200 houses are left even if we
share what we have how can we fit we are
living in fear because it's still
raining
it's hard to imagine that just a few
days ago home stood here the market was
alive and thriving children were
returning home from school the water
came down the hills and it came with so
much force many people could not save
themselves
the stream water came down with huge
rocks and trees after it bust its banks
Justine shows us where her home was
located she managed to escape with her
children some family members were not so
lucky
when we saw the water we ran it was very
scary it's very sad that I will not see
my relatives neighbors and my friends
again
nearly everyone in this Village is
grieving but they're also trying to
survive day by day Catherine soy kalehe
territory Democratic Republic of Congo
time for sure break here now